I've got a tattoo on my left leg; It means
left leg in Chinese.
Yes, I did it on purpose.
I don't have to worry about it interfering
with an Apple Watch, but it might screw up
an MRI.
Sup people, Trace here for DNews.
Thanks for coming by.
News broke recently that just like your grandmother,
the Apple Watch has a problem with your tattoos.
Apple fessed up and admitted tattoos can interfere
with the measurements of their newest device;
they believe the infrared lights in its pulse
monitor are bumfuzzled by differing light
absorption rates for skin and tattoo ink.
After all, pulse oximetry, or the measuring
of blood flow using light, has only been around
since the 70s.
If anything, this "problem" will make medical
and consumer tech even better in the long
run!
But the trend of body modification is a growing
challenge in the medical field mainly because
ink manufacture is largely unregulated.
Different artists will use different inks,
some make their own, using either inorganic
or synthetic compounds; but there's no standard
practice.
According to the Food and Drug Administration's
own files, "Color additives must be approved
by FDA for use in food, drugs, and cosmetics,
[but] no color additives have been listed
for injected use."
This is government-speak for no one checks
to see what's in that ink the tattoo artists
inject into your dermis, and that HAS caused
issues.
Magnetic Resonance Imaging uses giant magnets
and radio waves to image human tissues without
the use of radiating x-rays.
Before MRI scans patients have to remove any
metal, and cannot be scanned if they have
pins or plates in their body.
Without tattoo ink regulation, however, some
have unknowingly scanned themselves into a
world of pain.
Some black, red and blue tattoo ink contains
iron as part of the inorganic ingredients;
and though you're probably imagining a tugging
pain, it's more physics-y than that…
A 2009 study in the International Journal
of Environmental Research and Public Health
found when you run a strong magnetic field
back and forth across an iron loop (like a
tattoo) it agitates the iron elements sort
of like a rudimentary generator; but since
it's not able to spin and produce electricity,
the iron in the ink heats up to dissipate
the energy.
It's possible that it gets so hot it causes
swelling, pain and even blistering second-degree
burns!
On top of that, the MRI scan is distorted,
so the whole point is lost.
Of course, this was just one paper, and it's
pretty rare, but it can happen.
CT scans or CAT scans are simply x-ray scans
which compile a 3-D image.
Tattoos haven't been known to interrupt X-Rays,
but piercings can!
CAT scans require removal of piercings in
the region being scanned, nose, lip, ear and
tongue piercings all need to be taken out
to scan the head, for example.
When x-rays hit metal piercings, the beam
reflects off the thick metal ruining the image
and throwing dangerous x-rays around at random,
like water splashes.
But aside from messing up CAT scans, the Journal
of Periodontology found fifty percent of people
with barbell-style tongue piercings had chipped
their teeth on the jewelry, and the longer
they wore it correlated with receding gumlines.
Yikes.
Researchers in these studies recommend avoiding
tattoos just in case you ever need an MRI,
and talking to your dentist before getting
an oral piercing, but honestly, you do you.
You're going to anyway, right?
But if doctors don't assuage you, what about
how you're viewed?
Anthony dug deep into how tattoos affect the
opinions of those who carry them…
I'm looking to get a new tattoo, and don't
know what to get make some suggestions in
the comments!!!
OR or show me yours, i'm on instagram @trace501!
Thanks for watching DNews everyone!